for those of you who didn't go to the
first one just to it you know this is
really the second event that we've done
on the darkest and in a certain sense I
think the first one the emphasis was
more on music was the kind of home of
that of that event and architecture
arrives as a way of thinking about the
music which included the performer
fantastic performance and miller theatre
and so on and it was a nice discussion
afterwards maybe today it's a little bit
the other way around that we coming
let's say from the architecture side
towards the music side so I think it's a
great pleasure to welcome back your
hosts and the wonderful cast of speakers
today but just to sort of state the
obvious and maybe it's something that's
happening in these last two or three
years but certain figures like San
darkest haunt canonic readings of 20th
century architecture and within those
figures that continuously haunt there
are always figures that slightly escaped
once capacity to understand their role
and that's exactly why they haunt they
become Ghostly sozin arcus is not only
an enormously interesting figure of
scholarship and there are many many
stories to be told about cinakisz but
also darkest acts as a kind of
acupuncture point and on the on the kind
of canonic vision of what architecture
can be so for this reason i think maybe
this is not just this was it four and a
half months ago that we did the last one
this might be in the end the second out
of ten or something like that I do think
that one could as it were grinds
anarchists into the ground and then he
would recover again about from
historians that is about 10 years later
and again be very very fertile and that
in there since there is something
agricultural about scholarship that it
tends to work things over until they've
got nothing left and historians move on
and then return and I think it's an
artisans very much a figure that to
which people are returning and in
returning see everything else
differently I think is in Arcis even in
his own time had that
capacity to make everybody see things
differently this whole poly toe concept
liberate that and again it's too easy to
say so I shouldn't say it but
nevertheless if you read a lot of sin'
arcus not thinking about his place in
history he very much seems to be
speaking about issues that matter a lot
to design us today so I think at some
level his attitude to kind of
multi-dimensional thinking seems easy to
understand today and perhaps because
it's easier to understand today we are
able to score us to do more work than we
could do before there's not that early
resistance to trying to understand them
anyway people like Luca Brasi we're very
lucky to be affected by his own arcus
and the nature of that effect will never
be fortunately resolved but i think it's
of course a great pleasure to have the
great scholars on Seleucus here and the
great scholars and in the case of
kenneth on on on architecture and i
think we could stage once again the
holes in Arcis look at bruiser debate so
i'm going to shut up and let you take
over
thank you Mark I'm Rafael Estelle and we
have some extraordinary speakers tonight
we have first of all to talk about the
Courvoisier one of the foremost scholars
on the Courvoisier in addition to the
being such a scholar of architecture
Kenneth Rampton and speaking on behalf
of Xenakis we are fortunate to have his
longtime assistant of more than 20 years
shower and khanak who is also the
co-author with xenakis of the book the
extraordinary book music and
architecture and the translator and
editor of several other books published
Publishing's of writings of zin august
and david lieberman who has experienced
as an ox's polytope in montreal as a
young person and has continued
scholarship on xanaxs work as an
architect and as a professor at the
university of toronto mark was
absolutely right xenakis is a little bit
like ghost hovering over disciplines he
doesnt sit comfortably anywhere the
musicians if you speak with musicians
about cinakisz you'll he's a figure of
great reverence and every single a
musician needs to know and it is
required study in all of the music
horses to learn something of his music
however he is very different from every
other composer before and very different
from composer since he occupies a
similar position in architecture in that
his attitude towards architecture is
quite different than most other
architects he is really somebody that it
was working very hard to create
something and the question is what was
that something he had an extraordinary
of life he
as a young man had the misfortune to be
born at a time of great turbulence in
Greece and became involved of course in
the political events of that time the
change of governments the Nazi invasion
and he had a part of his face blown away
in a demonstration which he has an
extraordinary description of that event
I'll it I think this is my personal
interpretation this is the single event
in his life which marked him so much
that everything he did is basically a
reflection of this I did event in his
life that it was just seared into his
soul unto his body this is from his
formalized music it's a which is a book
about create using mathematics in the
creative music everyone has observed the
sonic phenomena of a crowd of dozens or
hundreds of thousands of people the
human River shouts a slogan in a uniform
rhythm then another slogan Springs from
the head of the demonstration it spreads
from the tail replacing the first a wave
of transformation thus passes from the
head to the tail the clamor fills the
city and an inhibiting force of voice
and rhythm reaches a climax is an event
of great power and beauty in its
ferocity then the impact between the
demonstrators and the enemy occurs the
perfect rhythm of the last slogan breaks
up in a huge cluster of chaotic shouts
and which also spreads to the tail
imagine in addition the reports of
dozens of machine guns and whistles of
bullets adding their punctuation to this
total disorder the crowd is then rapidly
dispersed and after sonic and visual
he'll follows a detonating calm full of
despair dust and death the statistical
laws of these of s separated from their
political and moral context are the same
as those of cicadas in the rain they are
the laws of the passage from complete
order to total disorder in a continuous
or explosive manner they are stochastic
laws here we touch on one of the great
problems that have haunted human
intelligence since antiquity continuous
or discontinuous transformation he was
also concerned with the idea of these
units of measurement we as a Greek
artist he was certainly well aware of
classical Greek mathematics and the use
of proportion and he was completely
bowled over by the use of the golden
section in the creation of the modular
in the Courvoisier studio he had the
good fortune when he escaped from Greece
to have his first job be working for the
Courvoisier as an engineer he had been
trained as an engineer not as a musician
as a musician he actually had the good
fortune of finding as a teacher olivier
messiaen he vanished to work with two of
the greatest creators of the first part
of the 20th century and he was obsessed
with the idea of measurement as an
engineer the idea of how you combine
from point to point what is the point
what is measurement what what is shape
and the I have a memory myself of going
to a very beautiful place the Sonoran
Desert Museum in outside of Tucson and
looking at the fact fantastic landscape
of the soir au cactus the ocotillo the
the impossibly shape boojum tree it was
named after the hunting of the snark
Lewis Carroll because it's a ridiculous
looking it doesn't look like it was
actually a natural form but it is and
the second reaction that I had after
just reacting to the shape of the
landscape was my god this looks exactly
like being underwater the shapes of the
plants were
and and the landscape were incredibly
affected by the environment around by
the wind by the shaping of shaping
forces of the landscape but it was
entirely similar to what one would see
with algae and coral growths underwater
it's just an amazing concurrence and
that's something of what is Anika's a
small part of what's an axis with
talking about when he was talking about
the concurrence of shapes and how we
barely have an idea of how to measure
the universe the world around us we are
talking measuring in rules of
centimeters and meters but we don't use
other measurements that should be part
of our normal vocabulary you're saying
the question of shapes has wide-ranging
connotations think of undulating snake
shape for instance it occurs in many
different places streams flow in the
form of sine waves not just in
mountainous areas but also across flat
lands Einstein providing an interesting
explanation for that in his view it
comes down to the rotation of the earth
this is of importance also in music the
presence and absence of tension also at
another time art films in human life to
shapes are everywhere at various levels
forms corresponding to some inner
necessity I believe that is what is
lacking today a theory about shapes
perhaps in 20 30 40 years time
fundamental shapes will be classified
along with their applications and
expressions in different fields of
observation in production and he goes on
to talk about Arbor essences tree forms
which he says is the basic form of
software writing the correspondences he
was seeing in all of these various forms
was part and parcel of his conception of
trying to create an architecture which
encompassed all manner of thinking he
was very much influenced by as I was
saying he studied music with olivier
messiaen the french composer and
one of the things that one of the many
things that messy all is famous for is
the idea of time flowing backwards the
conception of these non retrograde
herbal rhythms he was talking about
rhythmic passages mainly and he
described it as a magic spell he
associated it with the ancient
architectural idea of the arch and he
was associating it also with spiritual
beliefs he was deeply devout Catholic
but the idea that one can perceive sound
as space by having it flow backwards you
can take this idea as an August it and
make it much more Universal he was
saying at one point that it's very easy
to hear time flow backwards all you need
to do is to stop for three seconds and
you've just heard time go backwards your
mind just went to the period when I
stopped and you hear the sounds that are
being reformed in your mind that the
power of the mental construct is outside
time and he had the belief that music
itself is outside time it happens
forward in time in order to perceive a
piece of music you need to have it flow
through time but time is not an
intrinsic part of the musical experience
it's something that is just necessary
for its consumption in the same way that
architecture is requires space but space
is not necessarily the the construct of
which architecture is made we're going
to be talking about the concept of the
total artwork that's a suggestion that
Kenneth made talking about these two
extraordinary artists who collaborated
together on
some projects like the Philips pavilion
law to vet and we'll be talking about
the possibility of creating an
architecture which goes beyond the
bounds of normal conception of
architecture I thought it would be
useful to talk about the concept of
total artwork before we get into the
actual material which is the first time
that that term surfaces is actually at a
crucial point in the late Renaissance
there was a group of people who got
together in the home of noblemen in
Florence in Italy Giovanna and I body
and it was a famous group that may met
and were digesting the newly discovered
works of the Greek philosophers that had
been passed back into European culture
from the trade with the Muslim world
where the checks the texts had been
preserved and they were arguing about
the Arts in the ancient Greek world and
they came up with this idea from reading
Plato and Aristotle that there should be
this thing this total artwork it should
combine the the idea of poetry it should
combine the idea of music and should
combine action at you combined space it
shouldn't mind movement all of design
all all of the various arts and they
didn't know what to call this thing so
they called it by the Italian word for
work which is opera and it's the only
art form that was actually ever created
by a committee that I'm aware of but
they got together and one of one of the
major proponents of this new form this
total artwork opera was the father of
the astronomer Galileo the was composer
himself Vincenzo Galileo and they were
proposing that people try to
they create this new form and they
didn't know what it was they were
experimenting with all sorts of
different things it was not a terribly
successful venture until the composer
Claudio Monteverdi came along and showed
how one could integrate all of these
elements together in one unified total
artwork it was one thing that I one term
that got lost in the transition in
history that I think should be revived a
little bit was the value that all of
these people saw is one of the highest
virtues it's a very strange virtue
because it's not translatable the
Italian word is spread cetera which
means many things it can be translated
as nonchalance but it's also the
presentation of ideas with the seeming
honesty and directness so that a you can
lie and people would believe you it's a
little bit like George Burns line that
you know always be sincere if you can
fake that you can do anything the that
was one of the basic things that they
were talking about in the the production
of this total artwork the next time
jumping ahead the the next time the the
term total artwork surfaced in a big way
was in German digas optical spec that
was proposed by Richard Wagner and he
was talking about his own operatic
productions mainly the the ring of the
name lumen and up he actually stole the
designs of the architect Gottfried
semper to create the thyroid Veche
Fieldhouse the major thing about that
for the purposes of this discussion I
think is just to briefly mention
one of the tricks of that house is to
create a double proscenium so that you
have this in what bogner called a magic
space where the characters who are
mythic characters can step forward of
the back proscenium so that they seem
larger than the scenery itself they seem
larger than life it's this creation of
in a totally a loser II space that
worked much better than the theatrical
machinery that they were operating which
basically considered consisted in the
late in the middle late 19th century
rather of using steam and some people
were describing it as kind of a smelling
like a laundry but the idea of unifying
all of the arts was certainly the the
idea that that took that generation by
storm it was completely illusory
illusionistic production that they were
talking about in involved nurse time but
we come to the the present time I'll
leave it to Ken to talk about the the
earlier productions of the Courvoisier
but in terms of the collaboration
between Yama's on august and the
Courvoisier we have the productions of
the the couv on doula to het and the
philips pavilion as major examples of
their search towards a architecture is
complete hard work and Xenakis went on
beyond them to talk about and create the
what he called polytope which go take
the idea of the philips pavilion in much
more extreme direction
abstract direction that I'll leave for
Sharon and / David to speak about
meanwhile I think I'll just turn over
for an introduction to Kenneth brampton
if to talk about the Courvoisier and
we'll continue afterwards with the
discussion between us thank you good
evening very stimulating introduction
yes yes because it also concerns me in a
way I mean I think what is amazing about
this beautiful book music and
architecture which I've held in my hands
for the first time today and and tried
very rapidly to assimilate pieces of it
is is the is that what he contributes to
our understanding of the Courvoisier I
mean it's largely it's full of actually
a surprising number of essays by by for
me anyway bison arcus and and many of
these essays are incredibly illuminating
not only about his relationship with
ecology but about other people and it
reminds me you know there is this famous
anarchist incident so called in which
the Courvoisier in presenting the
phyllis pavilion her doesn't credits
anarchist at all publicly and the
darkest completely loses it quite
rightly and and later luca busy work for
credits in Arcis but but he local museum
has a great problem about crazy
crediting any collaborator basically
although that names of collaborators
were listed nobody was singled out
usually so probably the contribution
that cenar keys made to the police
division was a bit hard for him to take
particularly since the record suggests
that a rather awkward sketch was given
to
nakia since an artist transform the
sketch or totally basically and and is
the primary author of the other Philip
splitting up to a point i mean it would
be that's very important thing I think
to say you know which is that I actually
one of the virtues of architecture I
think but also one of its break
problematic aspects is that who is the
author exactly of many buildings it
would be difficult to say because it is
talking or hinting at total works about
a collective art work and many invisible
people are lost to history behind the
creation of complex structures where
they have contributed absolutely salient
elements which have have never been
acknowledged apart from the fact of
course there are some people who are
annoyed but there was a hint in
Raphael's presentation about that I
might have something to say about the
present the digital present and of
course you anyone who's at all familiar
with me realises that I qualify as a
dinosaur and more ways than one and
about the digital present what do I have
to say big question I very touching
thing there are many touching Testaments
to look obvious a bison darkest one is
you know just before they split actually
and as the knock is put it around ten
years before his death look obviously I
said it's 56 I think it's all going too
fast it's time for me to be buried I
mean I've to say I understand that
sentiment I mean the speed compared to
that time by the way has greatly
accelerated and the impact on it of it
the speed are many things not only
architecture I would say the impact of
the speed on democracy is devastating
actually as we approached recently had
to recognize I think with the deft
movements of the American Supreme Court
and he also said at that time you know
how that to him in a taxi i think is the
same conversation
only failures and he was referring to
his own work as failures the painting
and the architecture as failures and Zen
Ark is very generously says it must have
been very hard painful to him to to to
feel that you know and and so these are
kind of openers in a way I I wrote notes
of course and I then when Rafa was
talking I added more notes and I will
try to follow this kind of stochastic
scribbles here you know and one of them
is relates to something that I feel very
strongly which is we shall never finish
with look obviously because this protein
figure was was just you know it is
there's no there's no end to this figure
ever I think what this figure produced
of what this figures thought about in
the space of his lifetime and and all
the kind of you know vectors that
intersection is Posada and radiate out
from his persona in you know is is
astonishing and and in a way the two men
i think were very well matched you know
also in terms of their slightly outside
a character in the the beautiful book it
points out that the sin arcus in greek
means little stranger and you know they
were both extremely they were outside us
both of them basically and and the
knocking shows up in da car is is
obvious and he says you know I wasn't
interested in the object at all I was
interested in engineering any music he
gets hired in 1947 he is struck
immediately by the modular which has
just sort of been as it were synthesized
you know and also its connection to the
greek golden section etc and he would
use literally himself in musical
creations if i understand correctly the
modular you know apart from using it of
course in took a business office on the
work of the office which of course he
was bound to do since
the motors operandi of that that stage
in the office fear and I'm also struck
by the fact that Raphael mentioned is
that his he doesn't where do you place
him he does he he a fair use the term he
sits awkwardly amongst musicians and and
it struck me by the way also that
architecture sits awkwardly inside the
University what is it exactly you know
never clear University still keep on
with their department of architecture
but they don't really know what to do
with them you know they're there on the
edge of an embarrassment basically but
they feel they can't let them go you
know because what is this you know and
and because it is a mystery you know I
love the fact that an Italian you know
the word for craftsmanship miss tiara is
very close to the mystery that I think
architecture is I love that aphorism of
Ziza who said somewhere I tell them the
university authorities that an architect
is a specialist in non specialization
but they can't take that not even as a
joke you know and the lock is is very
critical of look abuses engineering
capacity he but he's very appreciative
of the man's intuition and the degree to
which he was in touch with everything
you know and he strides in somewhere
it's very beautiful tribute as
avant-gardist to the end and ends degree
you know which is perhaps in many ways
not how we see him today and this
reminds me of the total work of art
business and the problem of the total
work of art which is in a sense touched
on by were more than touched on by
clement greenberg famous essay Ivan
Carlton cage of 1938 where which is of
course totally against the total stock
apart and and because you know and of
course he has amongst other things
varner in mind I'm sure music drama etc
you know and Varmus well do you know
this question of great art and it's the
thin thread separating on occasion great
art from kitsch and
and greenberg it is a kind of cosmic
it's a cultural political question of
course and and it's very purest of him
not only look obviously a sense to seek
you know this the grounding of of the of
the Arts in their own their own sphere
of limitation and as a savior of their
capacity to variety just save them from
being reduced to entertainment archit
Ament is the term that luis fernandez
galliano is used you know of the
spectacular production of recent date
one has this problem I think of looking
at the spectacular production of recent
date between appreciating its exuberance
and having misgivings about its its lack
of boundary I think perhaps one could
put it like that that's an amazing
passage that refer read about this
xenakis on sound it reminds me of
futurism immediately you know but not
only because of the association with
political upheaval revolution inviolable
terrorism and counterterrorism and the
strange reference to nature cicadas in
the rain cetera I mean this this is the
kind of objectivity and but also
combined with the kind of very direct
passionate and then and visceral
experience you know I mean
life-threatening and so these are the
kinds of sorts which one is led to win
this under the theme of total walk about
and and and zone Arceus and look up
easier and what is amazing i think is
what you know the closeness between
these two men what the coverage of what
sinach is contributed to look obvious
work you know his his work on the
unitary epitaxial his work on the unity
and not he had free hand with the
kindergarten that
I believe was on top of the launch it's
a trios I think it's somewhere involved
with the kindergarten in the USA was
saying his involvement chandigarh it's
quite obvious that the sort of cooling
tower form hyperbolic paraboloid kind of
fast room I think they can be called
which appears you know above the
Assembly Building in chandigarh is
clearly humans and our keys and and then
the other things big surprise to me is
this climatic grid of xenakis and the
contribution he made to this question of
building you know housing without air
conditioning in India you know this
these tunnel houses very surprised to
see and realize you know I realize that
Charles careers tunnel houses which are
solving the most beautiful creations
also early in his career has probably
have an origin here in the tunnel houses
I can't prove that but anyway there's a
funny you know convergence there and
this question of you know some control x
in terms of shade but also induced
ventilation through those tunnel houses
this is all xenakis at work with luca
regime which brings 12 messy on and and
i didn't know the machine was so
catholic i mean in this kind of very
strange conjunction here that messianic
catholic but the darkest is an atheist
and look obviously also as a matter of
fact you know despite the fact that they
in there with their own private
misgivings I think enter upon this
design of the dominican monastery at
love to it after it I have just the job
for you he says I'm paraphrasing the
geometry of a dominican monastery and
and indeed we know and i think my fellow
routed to it you know the contributions
anarchist makes that we know of course
there many other properly contributions
he makes but this undulating you know
this undulating rhythmic syncopation of
the concrete Mullins on the ambulatory
of not to read you know is for sure
xenakis as is the strange device is
strange acoustic device
it was supposed to reflects that sound
out over the belly this is the this is
for sure as a as a desire coming I think
from the Courvoisier this idea of sound
because I mean that is the building
should should issue sound you know and
this and because it brings one slightly
back to greenberg that perhaps and here
you know we have this perhaps the thing
to be discussed you know which is the
whole long old adage of architecture
being frozen music but of course this
separation from music and architecture
and and across the complexities of space
and time and that the look of izzy would
correct want to build a carillon by the
side of Rochelle this is well about the
same time that he is in our cases
involved with him and Commission messy
and to design music to be you know
projected across the landscape you know
you know he uses this acoustic metaphor
in relation to Warshaw you know him to
the landscape around Ross long as in a
metal but also had the idea of it a
projection of the music in the landscape
with music by messing on well the church
would have nothing to do with this and
none of it happened either Karen ignore
the music of methane but you can see
that's the sort of thing with him this
question of of going beyond architecture
and in that sense of course to total
artwork in that the the architecture
should be an occasion for music music
you know and so their followers then you
know but before i mention that i will
quickly bring this to it close that you
know there follows of course after that
the philips pavilion but before i come
to that i wanted to say one more thing
about lotta rate which is that the
acoustic break up panels are quite know
what to call them actually these four
pentagonal three-dimensional pentagonal
forms that would be cast in concrete on
the side on the and the inner wall of
the of the megaron Tanaka's reckon
it is a macro good and and look
obviously is sort of that I like also
look of easiest kind of a little bit of
angst you know because he thinks it
looks a bit like German Expressionism
the 20s but then the NARC is very
generously says but he didn't do
anything to stop me from doing this and
the only reason why this they were not
built was because we didn't have the
money to build it we had a bloody
problem you know and then out his talks
in an incredibly generous way about them
what happened between him and the young
people who work for him you know and his
the way ideas evolved in the in the
office and and and and he had you know
the appreciation of them xenakis his
appreciation of the computer is amazing
i think you know also after the the big
conflict and the fight and moment that
look of it took a busy it changes the
office and this is a description of look
obviously as a person I mean I just find
it the generosity of this and the D and
also what he says about human beings all
together you know he says as a human
being he was a very he was an elegant
man with a certain marshal bearing
imposing at times he was a very close
secretive man I always thought he was
incredibly sensitive as well as terribly
fragile and that he constantly had to
protect himself under a semblance of
irony malevolence aggression bitterness
and sometimes even contempt I mean it
convincing description of this place and
although he was capable of professing a
certain admiration to the likes of Perry
gropius or John prove a in general he
was very severe with regard to his
colleagues you know I mean this that
sound that is so convincing to me you
know that and it's after this passage
that he talks about her you know Corp
saying only failures with
France to his own work you know it
reminds me of a very beautiful thing
which that Corbusier also said and I
realized this is a bit off the topic you
know what's this got to do with subtle
work about but actually i think the the
figure who who who enters into this
spiritual activity it is important and
and gives you a thinker better dimension
of what it is to do that you know and
what it is what is involved you know to
efforts on to look a busy I like
enormously every morning I wake up in
the skin of a donkey and the second one
is do your work in the bag of your skin
and give thanks to your creative this is
certainly what the NARC is did I think
and and the complexity of the novices
work I have two things to say that all
to end with that come off when roughly
over saying but I realize this is
somewhat scattered under and diffuse it
concerns hell maybe I forgotten what it
concerns that's the interesting things
in all of this well it concerns you know
his the scope of herbs analysis project
I mean it comes back to this total work
of art and also our yes the issue is
space and time and I was struck by
Rafael's reference to the you know
reversibility of time and how in a
conversation with me chars say which I
don't think is in this book now he he
repudiates this idea of the
reversibility of time and we shall
cherish is shocked by it and then he
says no it never goes back it always
goes force that was already said by
Heracles that's it you know very
beautiful also
amazing thank you
Thank You Kenneth I will now have Sharon
Connick tie a few of these various ends
this is a very complex topic we're
approaching so the diffuse pneus of what
we're doing is hopefully going to come
together in the discussion of the many
subjects Sharon Connick thank you thank
you thank you can thank you rafael for
the invitation thank you David it's
always a pleasure and then honored to be
sharing the podium with you many things
I Kenneth Kabul and your stochastic
presentations or is convincing and as
powerful as Jonas's I must say I hope I
can do as well because we've had a very
busy time I don't know whether you were
all aware of the fact that there's an
exhibit right now going on at the
drawing center at 35 Wooster Street of
Genesis a very very small selection of
Yana's archives an exhibit called none'
sonatas composer architect visionary and
there are many public programming events
and concerts and we just had a three-day
forum at Brooklyn polytech about the
past present future legacies of sanaa
keys so it's quite as anaki and busy
time right now so I've tried to put
together a couple of images and I have
to not really I have to apologize
because number one I am certainly not an
architect I am a musician and I'm not
really a scholar unfortunately I don't
have the time to devote to scholarly
activities the way i would like to
because it's kind of fallen upon me to
be honest excavator in a way and because
of his protein activities and very
prolific output his archives for example
at the bibliothque nationale
woodland of the library of congress in
in paris is about a hundred moving boxes
that you know we're slowly which were
they doing in do you know there's a
basic inventory but every time you go in
there it's it's incredible what what one
can discover so I see my role as being
much more of an excavator but not in an
archaeological sense because I think
every single aspect of Yana's work be at
his writings being biet of musical works
or his architectural projects of
realizations are such enablers in a way
and so the this excavation process is
one more not for archaeology purposes
but really out to you out to the youth
out to the future generations in terms
of means of reflection and of possible
creation but tonight's topic is
architecture as total artwork and it's
listed billed as a debate in debates I
think it's important to at least try to
define even if we differ on some
definitions what is architecture and
what is a total what is total art or
what is a total art work rather than
give any personal opinions I'm going to
try to just quickly give you an overview
of some of the solutions yaez himself
could have proposed this evening we've
always wondered who the mystery person
is in
the helicopter but here we see the Cobra
giannakis either on their way to or from
Brussels working on on the Phillips
pavilion this was not their first
collaboration because they were already
working on on that white together but
Kenneth gave a very fair background of
the collaborative process I think it's
interesting also maybe this is a little
site of archaeology that at the time and
this photo was taken I believe in 1956
Thomas was 34 years old Nicole bruza was
more than twice as age he was 69 years
old the Cobras a was 35 years his senior
and Jana survived Nicole busey a by 36
years so we see and Nicole brucey a had
been thinking about what finally was
realized as his aspect of the project of
the Philips pavilion the boy Amanda
clinique the electronic Rome he had been
thinking about that since the 20s since
yiannis is birth so his contribution and
and the possibility that the Philips
corporation presented to him to realize
this aspect of his work was quite
important and why he's so willingly I
think delegated the the actual
architectural designed to to the Nagas
so if as a as a musician I'm trying to
understand what is architecture I often
hear the word containment and that seems
to make sense and could I have the next
slide please next please or is there
something for me to touch can I do it
Oh perfect thank you great so going
along the lines of containment as long
as we're talking about the Phillips
pavilion we're fine even in his first
polytope which was done in 1967 it's
still contained within the French
Pavilion at the World's Fair 67 also
including the polytope to CUNY which the
first version was done in 1972 it took
place in the Roman baths in the city
centre of Paris but what do we do what
is the architecture of the total artwork
when we are jumped to his first polytope
that was site-specific in Iran in
Persepolis 1971 or his last polytope the
polytope Tennyson in in my sin agrees in
1978 what is architecture what is the
architecture of a total work of art I'm
kind of reminded of a quote I think
xenakis made to Varga it's a wonderful
book of interviews between Varga and
senaka swear he says each one of my
musical works poses a philosophical
question nowhere in the book does he say
he gives an answer though so I think
again senaka is giving us this question
what is the architecture of a total work
of art when doing his site-specific
polytopes I think we can continue the
conversation though from another angle
and that's one of immersion and sonatas
through his different polytopes was
getting more and more immersive and more
interested in that when the polytope
decree knee was reprised and in 1973-74
because it was actually commissioned in
the origin of the
festive and Oakland in Paris had offered
him to write an opera oppa ha in the
total artwork sense for its first
edition yiannis responded by creating a
polytope and when it was so
fantastically successful they took it up
again the following year and yiannis had
convinced the authorities that be
because it being a national monument he
was very very restricted with what he
could do in terms of the walls so they
had to build the scaffolding around that
nothing could be actually on the walls
they were very worried about building
codes and how high these these speakers
and lasers and and everything could be
and after the success of the first
version he would he managed to convince
them to be able to lower the the
apparatus so that the public who become
more and more not only immersed but also
interactively related to the spectacle
as it was occurring xenakis in some tax
sites this as being a huge technological
advancement for him so this and then
finally we get to this immersive idea
taking maybe yep to his diet the diet
oak was actually the second-to-last
pollito but it was supposed to have a
much longer life unfortunately the image
is a little bit too large for this where
we can see in just as terminology also
from polytope we go to diet oak diet
took something going through so not only
did he want the spectacle and the sounds
that he was creating within this
architecture he wanted also the urban
sounds to be able to participate so
there was a constant communication
between what was being performed inside
and the urban landscape and soundscape
outside in I think both Raphael and
Kenneth mentioned the idea of
abstraction this frozen aqus was the key
to creating indeed a total art work or
work of art and you can read here
exactly why he thinks that abstraction
is meant in the sense of conscious
manipulation of laws and pure ideas and
not of concrete objects through
abstraction these two arts he's talking
this is from notes towards an electronic
gesture which was actually published as
part of the book accompanying the
electronic poem in 1958 for the Brussels
for the Philips pavilion and and
that has contributed and and knock has
contributed Nicole musea and invited
them to participate and this this
article now this 1958 article is almost
read in certain circles as kind of a
manifesto for new media art so through
abstraction these two arts forms and
colors volume like lean towards a
philosophy of essences which suddenly
and gradually develops into mathematics
and logic we may also note just how
important it is that a new architectural
conscious that will emerge from the
beaten path of the plane and right angle
in order to create a space that is truly
three-dimensional by using the most
recent shelf forms from the theory of
elasticity you can see it's obviously
tainted by by the the forms that he had
developed for the filhos pavilion but
which he stuck by two to the very very
end in the drawing center exhibit there
is an example I don't have it here of
his one of his last architectural
projects was for an experimental
auditorium for the cicada musica in
Paris and again he he takes up this idea
of hyperbolic paraboloids
this confer the quote from the notes
towards electronic gesture the
simultaneous of a abstract evolution is
admirable in other areas of human
activity in commence demonstrated by
drawing a parallel to the advent of
modern abstract algebra around 1910 the
abstract current is so powerful and so
important that any of its detractors
within the realm of the Arts appear to
be inflicted by mental deficiency so
this is now 52 years old this these
thoughts and it's something that is
anarchist pursuit it was interesting I I
was reminded that in the Philips
pavilion when he was one of his
responsibilities was also working being
a musician being very much aware of
acoustics as well was the speaker
placement there about between their
their differing figures between 325 or
400 speakers within the Philips pavilion
and that's that image that was poorly
placed these are just some notebook
drawings of possible sound roots within
the Philips pavilion that that Janice
was toying with but in these these
musings and and also in some of the more
theoretical things he's always talking
about an acoustically inert architecture
therefore with thanks to electronics
thanked thanks to speakers thanks to the
fact of because he was a child of
technology I mean he had a huge belief
in technology that through that we could
create cinematic stereophonics but the
prerequisite was having an inert
acoustic architecture
and when he deals again sorry for
jumping around with his own architecture
and his own total spectacle I don't know
whether we would call it a total work of
art or not it's something we I'm more
than happy to debate with with my
colleagues and with you later on the
form of the diet cokes vinyl plastic
shell is the realization of a project
I've had in mind for over 20 years so
we're going back from 1958 after after
the Philips pavilion he was thinking
about this all the time actually the
next project he worked on in Nicole
music studio was for a huge stadium in
Baghdad and both he and Nicole brizia
got extremely excited about using the
actual stadium for new types of
electronic games when there weren't
olympic games going on they could use
the space for their own electronic games
it is a response to the perennial
unsolved unresolved question what
architectural form is to be given to a
musical or visual performance I say that
there is no unique answer but I also say
that the effect of the chosen
architectural form has an almost tactile
influence on the quality of music or the
spectacle performed in the time has come
to bridge the arts across oh oh no sorry
I thought there was another before he he
actually created the diet oh it began
began as a much more utopian project
called the woman which he called the
world polytope his original idea was to
connect in 1978 via satellites via all
sorts of technology that was available
extraordinarily expensive but available
a in and it was done for the
inauguration of the Georges Pompidou
Center billboard in
and it was meant to be the ambassador of
the bow board and Jana says reaction was
well we have to tell the world about it
let's create a world polytope let's do
something where Russia Japan the United
States East Coast West Coast South
America can all be connected at the same
time and and create a performance that
will somehow be linked to the
inauguration of the bow board
unfortunately due to budgetary concerns
this was never realized but we see this
utopian vision that today are becoming
more and more affordable more and more
realizable so many aspects of San
offices work has been so pioneering so
precursory that 50 years later they
still seem extremely contemporary yet
much more feasible the time has come to
bridge the arts across oceans between
confidence and among countries there was
no internet in 1978 why not weave
together the population of the earth
through the Arts by establishing a new
direct contact that overcomes the
barriers of language politics
parochialism racism and chauvinism in
short just as our universe is created
from grains of matter and straight lines
photon radiation are ruled by stochastic
or deterministic laws probability this
spectacle what hat was actually
happening within the diet oak offers a
miniaturized shed symbolic abstract
reflection of it in this way music and
light are united together in some sense
this is a kind of cosmic harmony of the
spheres of the cosmos which by means of
art becomes one with that of thought
to end with after he had created the
diet oak he was invited to give a
lecture on it and so a few years later
four years later he ends his
presentation as I will and mine with
this thought in reality and artist is a
theoretician a manipulator and creator
of forms and movement seen from the
point of view of art all of our
knowledge and our actions are but
aesthetic expressions of forms and their
transformations thank you thank you
sharon now have David Lieberman who is
going to speak about the diet hopes in
the polytope and continue this in
perhaps a few surprises we've had a
scholar we've had a musician and I'd
like to try and do something a little
different have we got the video
commencing thank you okay I've chosen
and
you
Oh what I was talking about was the idea
of outside time which is the conception
of being able to manipulate the sense of
time the component parts the the example
I was giving was in terms of being able
to understand sounds in retrospect which
is not turning time backwards but using
your mind to collapse the sense of time
the component parts of sound exist in
analysis mind outside of time that it
only takes a the passage of time to
experience a work of music or a sequence
of words in a sentence to be able to
comprehend what the sounds are but the
component parts of it exists outside of
time which you put together in your mind
I think that's a very important
distinction that I thank Kenneth for
accentuating that he was very strong of
course in maintaining the arrow of time
that time only flows in one direction
but I I wanted to open up for us to
explain a little bit about if i may ask
sharon to a
expand a little bit on the the ideas
that zanuck has brought to the studio of
the Courvoisier the for example the the
idea of the ideas that he was
translating in metastasis that he turned
into the architecture of the philips
pavilion you could begin to address that
well I think it's clearly neutral
recommendation between music and
architecture with the honest he was the
very famous example of metastasis being
preceding the philips pavilion and as
being almost a literal translation of
some of the forms that he was working
with musically but but metastasis itself
was very much influenced by the modular
without the modular we wouldn't have had
the same into stasis so it's not quite
the chicken and the egg but almost I
think I think it's Kenneth pointed out
that the there was we cannot
underestimate the personal relationship
that developed between the two men is
being extremely influential and in San
offices development as as an artisan as
an intellectual and and I think he'd
learned a tremendous amount he never he
never had the aspiration of becoming an
architect and it was only through his
his work with clear called boozy seeing
Nicole Busey as a model that he was
inspired to pursue that above and beyond
the pure number crunching as he called
it of being an engineer more
specifically I don't know I think I you
know I think the involvement of course
in the Phyllis pavilion n in the
electronical I just showed you that the
five polytopes that that evolved out of
that better his main Magnus opus it's
it's it would have never happened had he
had not been at Nicole Busey
Kenneth mention the the cooling tower
and Sean dgaf that would have never
happened had Nicole music not invited
yiannis to participate in such a way and
that the examples are there are lots of
them in here and it's it's it's I don't
know whether it's really the place at
the time to go into that kind of
discussion and if we try to stay focused
on it on the subject of the debate of
the total work of art the churn I think
you you raised something three honest
though not setting out to do an
architecture my tech would be slightly
different in that the extraordinary
opportunity of the architecture studio
and Kenneth would know better than any
of us is in fact that dialogue that
debate in discourse whether or not it's
credited as collaborators at this point
I don't that doesn't interest me as much
as the remarkable argument that did
exist between Luca Brasi a and xenakis
where I don't believe either of them
could have done what they did were it
not for that argument at the same time
so much of what the Courvoisier imagined
could not have been built without the
engineering of sanaa keys and I think
it's seamlessly the way liqueur boosie a
imagined architecture as the total
artwork xenakis was drawn into that
conversation and by virtue of his
fundamental mathematics was able to
resolve it both musically and
architectural II and I think it's that
necessity of the foundational principle
for our all architectural composition it
need not be mad
maddox it just as easily could have been
a set of philosophical precepts but I do
think we need that reference that
departure point and in this case that
was their conversation by the way I also
encourage everybody to go to the
exhibition of the drawing center and to
take the opportunity they have iPods to
listen to the relevant sounds with the
drawings to go through the exhibition
that way but I wanted to ask of Kenneth
was talking about the the collaboration
of the nagas and Luca Busey a but there
are times from the career of the
Courvoisier as a such a protein creator
where he went beyond the basic precepts
of architecture he was actually going
into Roche always is a good example you
were talking about the bell tower but
also the idea of the wall becoming
almost a performance instead of being
affected by light it affects the the
light in the space I I think I think an
interesting thing arises you know with
well to terms that come to mind that are
also i suppose difficult terms of ink
and lead to a lot of discussion i mean
one thought occurs to me is the idea of
kinases altogether you know this this
experience which is a bands on movement
in one way or another and the and how
that relates to from phenomenology you
know and our perception let me that
there's one thought and I related to
this very still I think remarkable book
by Steen I'll arrest nursing which is
the bear the title experiencing RPG
in one of the chapters of the book is
called hearing architect and there he
you know starts off by in his very
gentleman fashion saying you know how
surprised the reader must be too I
should propose the notion of hearing
architecture but then he speaks about
the acoustics of a space and how we
might speak of a space being warm or
cold solely because of its acoustics our
perception of this warmth and closeness
comes from the acoustics relevant from
the visual aspects of the other space
and I find that a very remarkable
compelling inside of his and the other
thing that the discussion up to now is
made me think Overlord is this question
there's difference between
materialization and dematerialization
because I think that maybe you know some
of the things we've been talking about
with regard to architectural music turns
slightly over this question of
materialization and dematerialization as
these two things intersect with the
relationship of nature and culture
because if one thinks of architecture
being more on the materializing side and
of its inherently static nature awkward
to use nature twice in two different
ways I realized but that that the the
play between nature and culture is
dependent on you know for example well
the movement of the Sun around a built
form that is fixed you know and the
ending and the seasons of the year and
the climate and all of that the
interaction between the the
transformations of nature and the fixed
thing which actually also might not be
entirely fixed because you know one
thinks of things like shutters and
windows which modify the thing in
relation to the climate on the light you
know of course only through the action
of the subject living subjects
moving subject also nature living moving
subject as opposed to the cultural
realization which is also of course not
in its materialization not like it is
also on its way to becoming a ruin you
know because it is also affected by time
over a longer to the directory of time
than the time you think of in relation
to human life and that on one side and
on the other side music which I think
Andy and the idea of the other
dematerialization it makes me think that
all of the novices polytopes were very
committed to a dematerialization really
I mean he may still have retained as how
I tend to see it so retained you know
this idea of being involved in the
creation of an architectural space which
would be like the bag gag stadium open
to full scope are the D materializing
performance dependent on maybe
acoustically on the container of that
perform but the primary thing I think is
the D materialized performance and there
the nature culture relationship seems me
is different because and I I don't know
what other people think about this
because it seems to me that the that the
kinesthetic light dynamic acoustical
musical piece is is in a sense a
paralleling of nature rather than you
know the nature culture relationship
scenes may be different but it is a kind
of paralleling of nature of the other
and abstract paralleling of the
processes of nature whereas the you know
as opposed to this aesthetic character
of architecture and I'm trying to make
this argument across this line between
materialization and Demeter lies
I mean you know and i think it's the
frustration of the architect by the way
you know that there is a kind of
frustration which is that it doesn't
move you know in other words there is a
kind of limit on the x passivity which
makes me think you know but that the
kind of sublimity of rochelle for
example was not quite enough four loko
busy i mean the last time i went to
rochelle some jew german tourists came
into that space and began to sing you
know kind of folk group and the effect
was was absolutely transforming you know
that then 11 was in the presence of a
kinesthetic phenomena you know depending
on the living subjects of this like the
living being singing as manifestation of
nature if you like but also count then
you can't get away from it sits at a
closed circle because there's also a
cultural manifestation and and but i do
think somewhere here there is this
between materialization if i can jump in
here there's an experience i think that
we all share if in terms of acoustic
space if you've ever been walking under
a parabolic ridge for example this is if
you look at kids doing having the
experience of walking under a bridge all
of a sudden there is this acoustic
environment which just invites people
shouting out they would call out in loud
voices because the sound just gives back
and it's just an instinctive thing that
people do when they encounter walking
under a bridge like that and there are
certain spaces which evoke certain
emotion motive responses like that the
the idea of dematerialization in space
creating a total artwork that were we're
discussing of zin aqus who by the way
created all of these things with very
limited technology we're talking
the dinosaur age he did these incredibly
elegant productions with almost
unimaginably primitive technology but uh
it's the same I go I come back to the
point that I started with this I eidetic
image that he had of his experience of
removing himself and seeing the abstract
representation of that experience in the
war where he lost part of his face being
in that demonstration with the explosion
the sound was the crowd scattering and
viewing it from the point of the
scientific point of view as a
mathematical construct the this is very
much of a piece with his idea of
abstraction one has to appreciate the
movements the idea the content of the
the work each one is as Sharon said a
different philosophical question but
it's posed in this identical kind of
language that's representative and as
for nature as an reality this gets back
to the concept which opera started with
that the Renaissance courtiers value of
speed etc that's the seeming natural
response that it seems to be honest
whether it is or not is another question
but it's a representation it's the ideal
to be a strip and towards leukoc
Philippe's in a way against representing
totally against representation yes that
it's the mathematical construct that
he's after in the representation is of
the mathematical construct they it's
logic mathematics that but logic need
not require a representation and I think
the one of the miss readings and I'd
like Kenneth
action between materialization and
dematerialization because I think one of
the unfortunate miss readings of Xenakis
his work has been only the graphical
mathematics is as important as a mean as
a structure of thought not for its
representation it's in the same way in
spatiality or dematerialization at a
similar time the work of the great
theatre director Peter Brook was dealing
with what he called empty space and that
the space existed by virtue of the
boundary set in the performance perhaps
in a somewhat nostalgic way I remember
once visiting shark cathedral on a grey
rainy day stepping into that space it
was dark it was wet bombed before the
eyes adjusted to that faint light coming
through the remarkable Rose window not
only did I hear footsteps in
conversations not only did I feel the
Warren stones where others had tread for
nearly a thousand years I think I heard
the voices of the choir that had some
there hundreds of years previously and
that I think is this dematerialized
remarkable register that architecture
can in fact deliver and I think it's
unfortunate that we have as in so many
ways much of the art world has reengaged
and sculpture was removed from its
pedestal artists such as and it's
interesting going back your comments
with Clem Greenberg and I think of David
Smith in particular removing sculpture
from the pedestal placing it first in
the floor of the gallery then in the
field as a way to engage or constructed
landscape but architecture until very
recently has still remained photographed
and
placed on a pedestal as an object rather
than this experiential condition of
engagement so though whether or not I
happen to really enjoy as an offices
music and his work it seems to me what
he promises given the available
technologies of today as projective
practice is in fact the brilliance of
the work and the resistance if you will
offered by the Corbusier in some ways at
the same time in the Courvoisier in
terms of his innovation that too goes
back to this crux of what architecture
can be what I was referring to earlier
to as the argument for the dance
it's a little bit off the subject but
going back to something that can said
before and then reiterated afterwards I
found one of the documents in the focus
is a text that i actually discovered in
the the Cobras a foundation called the
Cobra deconstructs the dominican
monastery at lateral head circa nineteen
fifty four and it seemed to me though it
was in FLC it seemed to me very clearly
articulated by sanaka sand so kind of
made a copy of it and I came home and I
was thinking about it and and I wanted
to show it to Jana was so alive at the
time and um he didn't remember and then
when the archives finally came to be
under my scrutiny a little bit I found a
document which I reproduced on page 54
in eunice's archives that show well if
he had it at home in that little and the
little design up here this is a frequent
personage that he would always doodle
during meetings or whatever but the
handwriting the handwritten annotations
that specify musical references musical
descriptions of the convent are actually
in Nicole bruise hand so the text the
text itself sort of and it seems to be
the text that they of presentation to
the Dominicans of the project seems to
be very serious and non-musical that's
not mix up who's writing here and it's
actually go call drew who comes in and
scrapes it out and says like an
orchestration like an instrument or like
it was this dynamics well there was that
dialogue between them the the the
windows the rhythmic placement of the
concrete mullions for the windows in
lotto vet they both had different names
for it and actually it speaks volumes
the differences that as a knock is
called them undulatory windows and it
was the Courvoisier who called the
musical windows which is a term that I I
take it that zanuck has detested well he
thought it would lead to confusions that
would be best avoided
I that this conversation leads me to a
thought which is that you know the
favorite son was out there generate
musician yeah all the rest of it you
know and I never never made it as a
composer basic but still you know you
can sort of if you if you're exposed to
that when you're yelling up you never
get over so I see it yes right so I
think that something of that is
absolutely I think we should take some
questions from the audience of you
please
there's a microphone coming so that if
you could stand up so people can hear
you there is something experiential
about great religious buildings in the
architecture itself independent of the
the religious belief none of the
doctrine and it reminds me of electro
happen to attend the other day about the
concept of core pole in 17th century
painting and how it was used to make
polychrome sculptures there's a relation
to this discussion I think because the
notion of corporal what they were
described in this lecture was the
material that was chosen to be as the
medium as a sculptural base for the the
figures it's a kind of wood that had a
red resident and they chose this wood
because with time the red resin of the
wood would bleed out through the skin of
the sculpture and a notion was that the
painting not represent two independent
of his reputation presentational value
very important to the Baroque period
there's also the subliminal the
substrata value of the materiality
itself and its capacity to to connect to
have the transcendent experience in the
viewer especially during these sessions
where the sculpture seems to bleed and
finally there's a connection here which
no one has mentioned which is very
interesting and what seems to be the
undercurrent here which is the atheistic
Catholicism that seems to permeate this
work in a sense if I describe it some
way you know there seems to be a lot of
parallel with the work of Goudy not the
Goudy of the finished buildings with the
Goudy of the method there's a famous
photograph that Gowdy has of his study
for parabolic figures where he put he
hangs some weights from the ceiling he
photographs it inverts it and that
becomes the form set you know according
to the test ended histories of it and if
you look at this this preparatory medium
is these hanging weights and you compare
it with the images of
the events that were created by sinach
is the parallel was extraordinary no I
suspect that there's a methodology there
which is you know the methodology
lesabre Oh Catholicism which creates
these ambient spaces you know which are
always moving figures no in the
transcendence of the movings figure and
the sense of you know of the very
primitive feeling of going to the
wilderness and being there at night and
looking at the stars which are heavens
away and which seem to be have you can
touch them and somehow using that as a
medium for reflection which you touch
the palm we talked about the ability to
to go back in time in a sense and then I
seems to be I think it needs to be seen
from the perspective of this religious
experience that people like to induce
ceremonies so I just thought these
thoughts out for you to do it reminds me
that one of the things that I just like
to say there's a wonderful other
translation in this book of that very
famous quote from Goethe who was not
actually claiming it for himself that
architecture is silent music frozen
music but he was saying that that was
what no vallas had said but he would
prefer calling it silent music and
actually I was looking up the German
word which was first I note which is
actually ambiguous it's in between and
it also refers back to in a funny way to
a reference to Aristotle who is talking
about the living presence of stones that
there is breath in stone that they are
wreathing in and out and changing in in
the course of time just a different time
scale and I think go to was referring to
that when he was writing that phrase do
you have something to add to no I mean
the other item I noted down this piece
of a materialization of Demeter
but you know we can conceive and I think
the intervention just made touches on
this point where these two kind of
impulses so intersect and the point of
which they intersect is not so clear you
know they say they intersect depending
on circumstances that unspecified
moments that one can't determine I was
thinking of this question of memory
because you know I'm someone who long
since obsessed with the thinking of
hannah arendt and this question of the
homework father and where she talks
about the Homer father one side of hope
of armor being the instrumental eyes of
who who eases the pain of the animal
labyrinth in in work and the other being
the home of father as monument builder
as as as a memory as it as a secure of
memory and without which you know she
says you know the futility of the
Everett of the current species and ever
occurring like that which there would
only be the futility of the species ever
occurring Liza and then woman talks
about stones this this question of of
buildings which have you know presences
that within them that have been there
for a long period of time you know even
when they are and also ruins there is
something that remains out of the
something is very difficult to talk
about in the end you know this is just a
phenomenological experienced
information to this these are not hold
to material elements but I'm just my
business about materialization and he
materializes I think it becomes very
heightened in the case of the darkest
because he straddles between these two
things and I think his he seems to me
that his ultimate deeper preoccupation
is to make a a work which is
dematerialized and has its impact
through this dynamic penis penis thesis
and he's like he's like a sort of fat in
a way but it's something that takes
place has beginning and an end and falls
silence I was left I mean it's an
experience that is within this span of
time right very intensive time but you
can says it's true maybe of all music
but I think it you know the abstract
character there's enough you know I
don't know is that aspect of its
dematerialization dependent upon so mark
Wiggly started the evening talking about
ghosts and he his previous talk he was
talking about architecture is dream I
think did very much of a piece with this
discussion which we could go on but
let's just take one last question we've
gone on for longer than we expected is
there one last one last question yes yes
please
thank you my question is actually
directed directly to Professor Frampton
earlier you said about how architecture
departments are the outsiders of
universities but as long as you have
master great masters like the darkest
and Louise heir who can correct map
curate like great masterpieces where it
makes us think of philosopher
philosophical ideas of nature and
culture space environment the
relationship between to fixing the
transient the analytical processes of
mathematics and the motive reaction
towards listening to the music a week
when we are inside a great building does
that as long as like architecture and
and humanities is able to produce that
does that not does that not guarantee
the survival of architecture department
well it probably explains that their
survival yes but I'm just I'm just
making the observation that you know
well sorry well it's hard to I mean I
think from the point of view of the
bureaucratic stroke academic management
of the University the architecture is
strange creature you know and that's why
I like so much this alvaro siza they are
specialists in non specialization thank
you very much I want to thank Ben proske
and Lucia a logian for and the Graduate
School of Architecture planning and
preservation for hosting this for
Kenneth brampton Sharon Connick David
Lee Berman thank you very much for
coming
you